comme plusieurs de ses riverains pepita
se trouve dans son salon quand un voisin
alerté par les flammes
la prix d'évacuer les lieux mais voilà
avec mes clés sait tous pourquoi il est
venu vous chercher ce qu'ils avaient
fait j'habitais là haut ça veut dire
quoi que votre maison était en danger
bas poussent le feu par l'adar oui
lincendie déclaré ce lundi dans la forêt
du plateau de chenôve était pourtant
maîtrisé dans la soirée mais les flammes
ont repris de plus belle cet après midi
elle menace désormais les habitations
inquiète le maire s'interroge sur
l'origine du feu
nous sommes j'allais dire très très
inquiet parce que le feu a pris des
proportions assez inquiétant on peut
s'interroger d'une façon tout à fait
j'allais dire inquiétante parce que
véritablement de voir une pareille
diffusion et départs de feu multiples ça
interroge énormément les habitants eux
aussi ont des doutes certains parlent
d'une erreur humaine comme le compagnon
de cette riveraine
il a pu discuter avec les gendarmes qui
veut en dit que c'était déjà nous qui
avait essayé de faire des barbecues au
niveau de la déchetterie
donc depuis hier lincendie serait lieu à
ces jeunes qui a hier l'un sandrine la
st die serez lieu à st une enquête est
ouverte elle devra déterminer les causes
exactes de cet incendie
pour l'heure les riverains ont été
placés en lieu sûr
il attend dans leur salle des fêtes la
maîtrise totale du feu